everybody I'm here with comedy legend oh
thank you so much for talking to me
after the show tonight how do you feel
about McKinney miles and I'm here within
32 years
miles will be a legend would you say
that we are good friends or great
friends or not more best friends know
each other but if we were to get to know
each other we would be best friends I'm
sure I'd love to hear that actually it
makes me extremely happy you were
fantastic on the show tonight years for
amazing everything he did tonight the
best I've ever heard really I love him
really very funny he was on fire as were
you then you were up and out of your
seat jumping around telling great
stories and ashamed of the spit-takes I
didn't it seems how could you possibly
be a shameless cheap are you doing we
did like it yeah tell me about your HBO
special I'm so excited for it live at
the Geffen it was fantastic you had a
couple great stories so they give me I
haven't seen it yet I'm really excited
to see I've heard good things you would
like it it's good I had it cut I had
about 20 minutes to fit in the HBO turn
around how do you choose the story
through away or as good as anything you
ever see how do we get to see that what
will you ever get to see that 20 minutes
yeah we've got time right now if you
want to do those 20 minutes we'll just
put it up I want to just pick your brain
real quick about some pop pop culture
questions some pop culture questions
yeah like right now people are really
excited about this new Ghostbusters
movie being made but there's some
controversy about it being an all-female
cast and even following that at all I
think it's a good idea right
might be great how do we let's see it
men decide they're hilarious
after so I think it could be great there
has been it was already been a
Ghostbusters with an all-male cast so
shoes we antique you one of controversy
it's very nice good travesty the drums
like it hey what about the book those
are the three movies are like best yeah
once they hear that you enjoyed them I'm
sure they'll make some last-minute
adjustments movies so far the best TV
special so far this year is live at the
Geffen it's on HBO thank you you guys to
check it out No thank you so much